[Music]
fortnite storyline has kept us guessing
for years culminating in freeing the
zero point now in chapter 4 a new
narrative has begun one set in the
present the future and the past all at
once a new era of fortnite a new battle
for Supremacy and the final mission of
the paradigm
[Music]
before we look forward we first have to
go back
[Music]
peace was finally achieved after the
imagined order were banished from the
island and the zero point was no longer
under anyone's influence this should
have been the end to get the orb of
power slowly fell dormant over weeks and
months this weakness was noticed by the
last reality a multi-dimensional faction
determined to destroy our Island reality
zero an attack from The Herald looked to
have fulfilled the last reality's
Destiny only for the zero point to
reawaken purging the entire Island and
seemingly ending this reality
four years we were led to believe the
heroes of this story are the seven a
resistance group attempting to free the
zero point from IOS control and to stop
the loop which forces us to continuously
fight every 22 minutes in a never-ending
Loop of life and death as chapter 4
began only one member of the seven
Remain the Paradigm after all the others
were either consumed by Chrome are
missing in action or fell into the zero
point and turn to shreds paradigm's
final plan came to fruition after
escaping to reality 659 her Homeworld
she began planning for zero fusion and
at the fracture event we found out why
[Music]
the zero point began remaking the island
its protection pulling in chunks of land
masses from multiple other worlds and
realities combining them into what we
have today but that Nexus couldn't do it
on its own it needed millions of Loopers
to help feeding it zero point shards and
the occasional chicken to fulfill the
task we then watched on as many worlds
became one what we didn't expect was
different times to be dragged together
from the medieval inspired Citadel to
the modern streets of sloppy Shores we
know the location of the zero point
thanks to the trailer and pinpointing
the moment it Retreats underground a new
Vault can be found and the zero point
words can be heard it's safe for now
elsewhere two key pois had emerged
brutal Bastion in the snow biome and The
Citadel in the medieval biome destined
to do battle here at the Bastion the
accompanying text reads the headquarters
of the reality Warriors is located among
the snowy mountains this may be a leap
in logic but it's believed that the
reality Warriors are here to protect the
zero point currently vaulted away the
scriptures here at the Bastion contain
the same Circle diagrams as the ones
found on the Vault itself are the
reality Warriors an ancient version of
the seven and if so why are we still in
the loop destined to replay the same 22
minutes over and over again if this is
where our heroes live then the Citadel
is the home of the enemy
[Applause]
the Ageless is itching to fight the
moment he sees a Potential Threat
according to the architect of this story
the Donald we called mustard the chapter
4 island is the earliest imagined order
we've ever seen before and to back this
up we just need to take a look at the
banners the centerpiece of the io symbol
is here the mark of Geno according to
law found in the Marvel comic book run
Geno is the father of two members of the
seven named in the most literal way ever
the imagined and the order they revealed
Jenna wants to create the perfect
society and began experimenting on his
own children to make them perfect he
would send them into the loop to see if
they could Escape it and if they didn't
do it quick enough he changed them
regardless of what they wanted this led
to both women hating their father during
the Collision event Geno was felled by
his daughters falling into the zero
point alongside the imagined thought to
be dead yet that's not how Jenna works
General rebuilt himself across multiple
realities just like the zero point did
this season this all leads to believing
Geno is the Ageless I mean look at them
they have to be the same guy yet there
is more to this story thanks to the
descriptions we know the Ageless is in
fact a snapshot a version of a person
left inside the loop that's the reason
why we see so many Jonesy skins each
with their own fading memories
on the island are a number of NPCs with
memory still intact all of which offer
an insight into the chapter ahead and
they all seem to be choosing aside the
Frozen Red Knight has taken down
Kingdoms in the past now on the island
she's setting her cold Gaze on the oath
bound this indicates she intends to
fight the Ageless whereas raptorian the
brave has reluctantly sworn allegiance
to the Earthbound and check this point
he also admits this place is a little
too perfect Too Perfect remember
General's remit to build the perfect
civilization indicating again this is
one of his realities the general
snapshot left here to rule the Empire he
is oath bound
we haven't come to the island all alone
one of our allies is still here Amy the
scientists artificial intelligence who
helped us many times in the past
extremely annoying but highly reliable I
am the scientist's favorite so it has
been programmed and so it shall be our
first mission in this new world is to
find the paradigm's final recordings and
we are set up with a final task a
strange operation all about rocks one of
the realities brought into chapter 4 is
shattered slabs a quarry with a brand
new element found the purple rock known
as kinetic ore a rock that can absorb
energy and redirect it effortlessly
probably the greatest thing in chapter
4. the Paradigm asks us to take a
different set of rocks to the kinetic R
Quarry these rocks we placed here are
not from this world they are from
another reality and it turns out by
leaving them there those rocks have been
refined and now are 100 times more
powerful than kinetic awe so powerful
Amy tells us what could happen if they
get into the wrong hands
have been
for hundreds of times more powerful more
than enough of this stuff and untethered
day I could mind blend this island into
a big old existing smoothie
wanted to wish I do not I'm
totally cool I believe the kinetic art
is part of what became the pure portal
the io once had think back the purple
blocks that could redirect the power of
the zero point to transport someone
anywhere in reality if this is true then
right now we have gone back in time we
may be responsible for creating the
bridge what happens next is likely to
set up the entire chapter of fortnite
Amy who is now growing more chaotic and
increasingly craving violence with every
new encounter somehow gave the new
special rocks to the Citadel I tried our
special rock gift the top night guys
studying them so I
sent him a message
he said something like your gift
intrigues me but do you truly know what
you have given us an unnamed Knight is
now researching them but who could it be
in my opinion there are three
possibilities about the person
researching for tanium it could be a
whole new character we've never seen
before it could be another version of
Geno as we know the Ageless is a
snapshot or it could be Midas his
long-awaited return is imminent and it
ties in perfectly to the plot We Believe
Midas wasn't IO operative who
specialized in doomsday machines yet the
machine created in the device event in
Chapter 2 Broke the fabric of the loop
and midas's real intentions were made
clear destroying the loop completely
Midas also has a long forgotten night
themed skin without any links to the
plot of fortnite at all and regularly
Donald mustard tells us how important
Midas is to the story he is alive he
wasn't eaten by a shark and now Midas
Rex is getting some air time on top of
that there is a nightly version of
midas's daughter in the game right now
scrap Knight Jewels talk to her and
she'll say the tech on this island is
intriguing and she's willing to work
with anyone who can teach her about it
even the oath bound the unnamed Knight
studying the Rocks asks us to defeat his
boss the Ageless Champion again this is
something Midas would likely ask us to
do moments after doing this a portal
design was spotted in a nearby Tower in
this region and it will slowly be built
over the next month and it appears it
may be linked to a mysterious character
known as the rift Warden that info was
given to us by Jules yet again finally
we know Amy's plan too I might be able
to build an experimental exoskeleton out
of this ore can you help me I distract
myself from the total you know what if
humanity and we both left to regret it
probably what do you say I wanna help me
build my body she intends to create an
exoskeleton from that refined can
kinetic or we created the only material
strong enough to contain her so next
month she won't just be an AI voice in
The Wind she'll be standing alongside us
it's unclear if her chaotic nature will
be good or bad for us but I can't wait
to find out
[Music]
I'm Adam you're awesome it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
foreign
[Applause]